[Musique]
après avoir alimenté le flou pendant
plusieurs mois Joe Biden a finalement
annoncé son intention d'être candidat au
présidentiel de 2024 le démocrate veut
se faire le défenseur de la liberté des
droits individuels mais dans un pays
polarisé avec un taux de popularité peut
reluisant et face aux questions que
soulève son âge à quel point peut-il
espérer un second mandat je pose la
question à la journaliste indépendante
Sonia Dridi elle est l'auteur d'un livre
intitulé Joe Biden le pari de l'Amérique
anti Trump on la retrouve à Washington
sur Dead ready merci d'être avec nous
Merci à VOUS bon
on en parlait dans la présentation l'âge
de Monsieur byden à quel point est-ce
que ça vient jouer dans la course qui se
présente pour 2024 pour lui et bien
c'est vraiment la préoccupe la
préoccupation principale des Américains
des démocrates notamment parce que de
toute manière les républicains depuis
déjà son élection le se moque un petit
peu de lui parce que ils disent qu'il
est trop âgé même s'il a juste deux ans
de plus que Donald Trump ça se voit plus
sur Joe Biden qui est marqué qui semble
plus fatigué et chez les démocrates
c'est vraiment le souci premier
d'ailleurs selon un récent sondage 51%
des démocrates ne souhaitaient pas qu'il
soit le candidat pour 2024 parce que
voilà il affaibli il a encore toute sa
tête moi je vais régulièrement à la
Maison Blanche je le vois lors de ses
discours je me rappelle même de l'un de
ses discours au lendemain des élections
de mi-mandat il était regonflé à bloc
parce que les démocrates avaient fait
des des plutôt le score et on le sentait
très à l'aise parfois il fait des très
bons discours parfois on le sent très
fatigué donc ça dépend et du coup pour
les démocrates c'est vraiment le le
souci principal parce que sinon quand on
leur parle de son bilan la plupart sont
plutôt satisfaits voire très satisfait
Joe Biden a fait passer des réformes
historiques sur le climat sur la santé
donc c'est vraiment le fait que
finalement c'est un pari risqué de
parier de nouveau sur Joe Biden pour
2024 bon quelles sont ces chances de
succès dans ce contexte
alors s'il fait face à Donald Trump de
nouveau on semble aller vers un remake
un match de nouveau entre Trump et Biden
pour 2024 il a de bonnes chances parce
qu'il a remporté l'élection une fois
contre Donald Trump et a priori il a de
bonnes chances de pouvoir la reporter à
nouveau contre Trump si jamais il y a
une surprise et il y a un candidat du
type rhum de santé donc le gouverneur de
Floride qui est assez populaire un
beaucoup le voyait comme le principal
rival à Donald Trump même s'il a pas
encore annoncé sa candidature là ça
ferait vraiment une différence parce que
Ron de Santi ça apparaîtrait vraiment
plus plus jeune plus dynamique donc si
ce s'il fait face à un personnage comme
Rome De Santis là ça peut être plus
compliqué pour Joe Biden mais run De
Santis est en train de chuter dans les
sondages Donald Trump malgré toutes ses
affaires judiciaires et sa récente
arrestation c'est comme un phénix il
renaît toujours de ses cendres il est
encore plus populaire qu'avant donc si
c'est voilà on assiste à un match Biden
Trump Biden a de bonnes chances de
l'emporter à nouveau et c'est pour ça
que les démocrates veulent parier à
nouveau sur Biden parce que pour
l'instant ils sont assez résignés ils ne
voient pas quelle serait alternative à
Biden pour espérer gagner contre Donald
Trump donc c'est une on refait un peu si
on va revoir ce que l'on a vu on
pourrait revoir ce que l'on a vu lors de
la dernière campagne électorale
essentiellement rapidement
oui et c'est assez déprimant pour les
américains notamment les jeunes qui
voient deux candidats quand même assez
mal aimés dans leur partie Donald Trump
parce qu'il y a une partie des
républicains quand même qui s'en sont
détournés et Joe Biden parce que s'il
est
âgé il représente plus le l'espoir de la
jeunesse donc c'est assez c'est assez
déprimant pour les Américains de voir
qu'on va arriver finalement peut-être à
un déjà vu quoi ce match Trump Biden en
les partisans de Monsieur Trump Sonia
dready Washington merci infiniment
d'avoir été des nôtres
merci à vous